this is Startalk we're looking for
Cardassia we're looking for Bajor all
these wonderful places that supposedly
exist and let me ask you the following
if we find them how will we know that
they are habitable what is the
classification Andrew how do we know
something is a world where actually
there's something never mind the the you
know sort of fictional way of saying Oh
anything can live anywhere right which
is true but non-fictional II what do we
need to look for to make sure that life
actually can live somewhere on a planet
well right now one of the big criteria
out there that scientists use is looking
at this habitable zone around a star
right so this is what we affectionately
call the Goldilocks zone right it's not
too hot not too cold and on the surface
of a planet that is meaning that how far
away it is from its parent star so in
terms of liquid water being able to
exist on the surface so if if the planet
would be too far away from its parent
star then the water would basically
freeze out on the on the planet right so
this most recent discovery of Proxima be
right those of you heard this Proxima
Centauri is a probably the closest star
to us a mere four and a quarter or so
light-years away from Earth most recent
studies after literally decades of
people trying to find a planet around
there seem to suggest that there is a
planet there maybe one to two times the
mass of our planet orbiting in what we
might consider that habitable zone is
there life there I'd at this point I
don't think we can we can just it's
speculation right I know we haven't
really we have to remember we haven't
actually observed the planet we haven't
actually directly imaged this planet or
where we're detecting the the effect
that the planet has on its parent star
right in this case we're looking at
wobbles of the star caused as planets go
around
they're post star the star actually ends
up wobbling because of the gravitational
pull and tug of that of those planets
and what's amazing is that we have such
exquisitely sensitive enough instruments
today that we can actually take those
wobbles measure them and and understand
like what how many planets are orbiting
around that star what their masses are
but to take it to the next level is what
I think would be really take is
understand like does it have an
atmosphere we know that it's one to like
in Proxima be a case we know that it's
one to two times the mass of the earth
and with our understanding of planetary
physics we think that it's a it's a it's
a rocky terrestrial type planet so has a
rocky surface someplace solid we could
land on right but does it have an
atmosphere we don't know that some are
how do we find out whether there's
atmospheres around other planets is
there a technique or techniques that
actually will give us that scientific
handle on whether there's gases
surrounding a planet yeah absolutely but
it requires a chance alignment because
so the method that Andrews talking about
is making use of this wobble but there's
another method that's called the transit
method which is when the star actually
goes sorry the planet goes in front of
the star and blocks the star's light
from us and we see a dip in that star's
light but that can only happen if you
know that solar system is in line with
our point of view and in theory the
stars and all of their potential planets
are in random directions from us so not
every star is going to have its planets
going between us and them but when they
do the cool thing is that you can
actually monitor this star's light not
just the brightness but actually the
content of That star light the
metallicity sort of the spectrum of That
star what type of elements it has and
when the planet goes in front of it if
there's an atmosphere some of that light
goes through the planet's atmosphere and
then that changes what the star light
that we record is and we can subtract
one from the other because when the
planet goes around the back of the star
then that signal goes away so
you can figure out what the atmosphere
of that planet what elements it's likely
to have and Chuck what would you do if
you found a comedy club on Proxima B I
probably would make sure they have air
first yeah and then maybe I might take a
booking no the first ever stand up in
space Andrew you had something else that
on first I just think that I'm so
excited when I hear that the idea of
being able to have this this chemical
fingerprint of the atmosphere because
let's take that to the next step if we
could actually detect the chemistry of
an atmosphere of an exoplanet we and we
could tell what what's there imagine if
we found things like methane or wait
wait methane is like cow farts why would
I be excited about finding cow farts
cows are on the planet
oh it's also the funniest planet let's
be farts do make everything funnier
right just last I mean it's it's just a
rule yeah okay factly think of it it's a
potentially a sign of life right
potentially and are things like
chlorophyll mmm that wouldn't that be
interesting
or how about greenhouse gases or
something like that so there could be
some very interesting findings that
could indicate very clearly that there
would potentially be life on these
planets wonderful and I just say that I
think it's really funny that the nearest
star to us is the one that took us so
long to find a planet around it's kind
of like when you're like looking for
your glasses and you can't find them and
they're on your head that is an
excellent point yeah no I think that's a
very good point sometimes the most
difficult things to find are the things
that are right near by but faint
approxima be you were there all the time
hahaha wait isn't there a song from the
1980s like that the search is over you
were with me
all the way
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]